Yeah, no, I was looking at that. What's
that crazy lady's name? Laura Loomer.
The lady jumping Nancy Pelosi's fence.
Oh yeah, she uh, camped out on her yard.
You know what made me think like how
flux Nancy Polosi you own that house.
Where's she getting all that cash?
Yeah. What's her net worth now?
A couple of hundred million. Really?
I forget to do what she in business.
She came from a hardcore political
family in Baltimore, I think.
And there's so much dirty money
she's been doing. She's, what?
100 million.
I was waiting on us.
She's worth 100 million estimated,
but that's like,
I don't know if it's a one
of those online network.
Where does she get her money from?
Oh, you gotta be Shit. You know what?
Maybe she's good at Jack around
Jamie keeping her a per diem.
Per Diem? Yeah. What do you mean what is
the, what's her national annual salary?
Well, she just started getting it for
this job. Wouldn't it be a 450 gram?
Wow. No, no, that's, that's
the net worth of five.
Which net worth or a median net worth
now this persons, okay. Congress person.
So it can't be anything
higher than an sis something.
So it's probably not more than 186 all
her good work she did with the Clinton
Foundation. Oh, speaker of the
house gets (220) 300-0200 grand.
She's where the hundred million dollars.
What in the holy fuck is that?
How has that, and she does have
a big wall around it. Please.
Not enough to keep Laura.
Laura Loomer is not an athlete.
Steve's right over that son of a mess.
It's not like she's a par core
athletes. Fuck. Did she get over that?
You show up with some illegals,
illegal immigrants or whatever,
undocumented workers, whatever issues.
She chained herself to Twitter.
I know she did that to that broads. That's
right. She's going hard for attention.
It's, it's very
interesting when these, uh,
these people just try so hard
to make it into the news. Yeah.
Well they're looking
for a contributor slot.
They're looking for on one
network or another. I think
that's what they're doing.
You have to now a days. I think that that,
I think, at least my theory is anyway,
if you want to be a paid
contributor for a network, no,
it doesn't matter which network.
You'll got to stake out a position, uh,
that involve some crazy,
right?
You've got to be like you how they get
be all in for president Trump or you've
got gotta be all out. If you live in
the center, that ain't happening. Right.
Nobody wants to hear from anybody in the
middle because that Shit's not picking
up the ratings at all. So no one wants
reasonable middle right now. No. No.
The only time that I think reasonable
middle would ever work out as if the two
ends are so fucked up and they're
fighting so hard on the opposite end,
it's like someone's like, God, surely
he's got to be a reasonable middle.
And then someone comes along.
It's almost like the people
gotta be screaming for it,
but right now it doesn't seem like people
are screaming for centrist position.
It's like a war one trench
warfare. Right. I mean, that's,
that's the way it is with the government.
Shut down right now and I'll close.
He's sitting over here in the mud and
president Trump's sitting here in the mud
and nobody's given any ground
and they're just stare,
just occasionally taking a shot at
each other, throwing a hand grenade,
and nobody is making any, any
movement. So I, you know, again,
how do they shut the, or how do
they stop the shutdown? You can't,
if you're not talking, if you're not,
if there's, if there's no effort, you,
it's not going to happen. So everybody's
looking at this right now and thinking,
you know, where's it go? It's affecting
the markets. It makes us look like morons.
Uh, I mean, not that others aren't.
I mean, look at, look at Britain,
right with the Brexit thing. Look at
France with the yellow vests. Look at the,
you know, Germany's having a tissue.
So you know, everybody's having some,
some problems, but you know, we
didn't need to add to the noise.
John Stossel had an interesting video
that he put out where he's saying,
what this does actually highlight is
that there's a lot of things that the
government does.
It really should probably be privatized
and we wouldn't have these issues.
Does that, I mean, it Kinda
made sense to me, but I don't
know a lot. Yeah, no, I, I'm,
I'm a small government person. At the
end of the day, I think, you know,
there's certain things that we need
to rely on the government for a,
and one of them would be of course,
national security. Terrific. You know,
collection of federal taxes. Okay, fine.
That they're going to do that regardless,
but otherwise just stay out of my kitchen.
Right. Don't, don't, you know, and so,
and that's why I've always been surprised
me that the Republican's problem I got
with them is,
you know,
you can't sit around and argue for small
government and then try to tell people
what to do with their bodies or who can
get married and who can't get married.
Who the fuck cares? Right. Just don't,
don't hurt people. Be a good person.
Get on with it. I don't need to
celebrate your lifestyle, but just do it.
I really don't care. I don't expect
you to care about my lifestyle.
I don't care about yours.
But the Republicans have always stuck
their nose in this and your key.
You can't make that argument for, for
wanting small government and you know if,
if you just want to step into
people's bedrooms all the time,
it doesn't make any sense.
And I think the only reason why they do
it is because it gets people excited.
They get to run to, to, to vote for them.
I think when they take these positions,
it's not like these are really having an
effect on their lives or at some moral
stand that they must take
because God wants them to do it.
I think they do it because they
think that it's going to get,
it's going to shift the pole one way
or another and it's going to get people
excited about them possibly making some
sort of a difference that they feel is
going to significantly
affect their position. But
do you ever get to the point,
I mean I don't know whether
that's going to happen,
but you would think that you've got the
people on the hard right in the hard
left. They're not going to shift.
Right. That's not going to happen.
You're not going to move those people.
So like everybody always talks about
decisions are made by that small group in
the center. So at what point did
the group in the center find it?
Put their hands up and go, you
guys are all fucked up. Right?
How about a third party that's legitimate,
not a libertarian party because
that's hasn't been working out. Um,
but something that creates a little bit
of a different dynamic and we're never
going to get term limits. So that's, you
know, tilting at windmills but maybe,
you know, maybe we get that multiparty
thing going that uh, again. Okay.
[inaudible] it's pie
in the sky. Well, crap.
Closest we ever got to it was Ross Perot,
right? Yeah, pretty much. Yeah. Yeah,
he was,
it was a piece of work,
but we took out a whole,
he took a block of time,
I believe it was a half an
hour on national television.
He bought the time to explain
how you're getting fucked. Yeah.
And explained taxes and explain all these
different things and, and people like,
wait, what? That's how it works. It's good
TV. If I can go back and find it. It's,
it's Ross Perot was good TV. I'll
show you what I'm doing here. Yeah,
I see. That's all that's all
fucked up. And here's Reagan. Fuck.